hot take coming in actually I don't even
know if this is a hot tag this is kind
of my observation solo didn't do too
well fans are pissed I see videos being
made I see tweets being made there's a
lot to say tell and digest about the
current state of Star Wars right now and
this just might take my observations on
it which I feel like it's gonna piss off
half of you and I am sorry for that in
advance but there's just a lot to talk
about here because the fans are speaking
the fans are kind of turning on Star
Wars right now I shouldn't phrase it
that way fans who love Star Wars still
love Star Wars just they're gonna pick
and choose certain elements of Star Wars
that they like ostracize the rest that's
where it's going right now and I haven't
seen that since well since the prickles
came out there wasn't social media
around when the prequels came out so it
just seems like more now but trust me
it's the same thing and don't take this
as facts or law don't take it as
scripture it's certainly it's it's not
heavily researched this is just my
opinions my observations on what I'm
seeing and I assume if you're subscribed
to my channel you come here for my
opinion so here we go fact is in the
current state of things Star Wars isn't
what it once was whether or not you
think that's a good thing or a bad thing
that's up to you but it definitely is a
different kind of Paradigm the Star Wars
movie about the most beloved space
Smuggler Captain ever that includes
Malcolm Reynolds yes open to what 85
million dollars or something like that
under 100 million for a Star Wars movie
that's pretty disappointing and there
are a number of people who are blaming
solo coming out so close to Deadpool 2
and infinity War that's why maybe that
plays into it to a degree I don't think
that's the whole reason why and even if
it is the reason why it doesn't chase
the fact that it's a Star Wars movie
like if this movie had come out 10 years
ago or five years ago when lined up with
back to back one weekend has Avengers
Infinity War the next weekend has
Deadpool 2 the next weekend has solo a
Star Wars story I feel like Deadpool 2
would be the one that took a hit be like
I want to see what happens with Avengers
because it's 10 years leading up to it
in a Han Solo movie yeah or maybe not
maybe people just never wanted this
thing I just never seen a time when a
Star Wars movie wasn't the gravitational
force dictating how much money other
movies are gonna lose like it should
have been solo is dictating where
Deadpool goes and how much money
Deadpool's not going to make because
solo came out so close close to it I
never thought I would see the day when
that Star Wars movie didn't make as much
money because it came out so close to
Deadpool this is kind of shocking to me
and I feel like the disappointing solo
numbers and the fan backlash one comes
from the fact that yes you've heard it a
lot and I'll say it again here fence
never really wanted to see a Han Solo
movie when you know everything about
someone when you have all the secrets
you're like all right well now I know on
to other things generally speaking you
can always make a backstory to something
we can make a backstory to the Han Solo
backstory find out how he got on
corellia so why not make a new hope the
Han Solo backstory that works but I also
think the fan backlash is now that we
are four movies into the Disney Star
Wars movies I'll call them that fans are
starting to see how this Saga lines up
with the other Star Wars movies how it's
different and how it's very different
and I believe they're starting to get
pissed because of the promises made
versus the Promises Kept or rather
promise is broken when Kathleen Kennedy
was sitting down with George Lucas and
they were announcing it George Lucas is
like I'm going to sell it to Kathleen
Kennedy and Disney she said the main
thing is to protect these characters
make sure that they still continue
needed to live in the way that you
created them at no point there does it
sound like MO the characters you love
from the original trilogy are going to
be dead by episode nine they're dead
they're gone
as for the most part I mean there's a
rumor that Lando might be in episode
nine I don't want him in episode nine
not because I don't love Lando but
because I don't want another character
to die as long as Lando is not in these
new movies I know he is out there
somewhere probably running vespin maybe
he's doing fun missions but he's alive
right when he comes on screen oh my God
and the old crew being killed off to
make way for the new crew doesn't sound
like the merger we were told it was it
essentially sounds like a hostile
takeover which is how a lot of people
are interpreting these movies let the
past die kill it if you have to oh great
[ __ ] you too and we've always been told
the core Star Wars movies it's The Saga
of the Skywalkers how can it be The Saga
of the Skywalkers when there is one
living Skywalker left whose last name is
solo which is a [ __ ] last name who
will probably die by the end fact is the
focal point of all of this is
essentially The Last Jedi with the force
awakens people were like yeah I mean did
use the same beats as before but Star
Wars feels like it might be back rather
that was some people other people like
me were like Star Wars is back
that was an exciting time Last Jedi was
like oh my God
it's not just what they did with Luke
which was take that Galaxy's greatest
Optimus who face down with the emperor
because he believed he could turn his
father good which he did and he turned
him into the old grumpy Uncle you don't
want to come to the barbecue that sucks
but it's really the smallest scale of
any Star Wars movie it has plot points
that are useless they literally go
nowhere the movie is essentially the
slowest chase scene ever between the
resistance and the first order it has
modern day jokes your mama jokes cell
phone jokes and it has social issue
commentary which so those Star Wars
story in the Droid that hammers that
home and it takes the escapism out of
Star Wars I'll touch on that more in a
bit but when I first saw the Last Jedi I
had that feeling a feeling I'd never had
in a Star Wars movie before where I felt
like I was watching characters not from
a galaxy far far away but from our own
Galaxy and our own solar system our own
planet from the intro the way Poe was
talking to Hawks I was like that's
that's from our world that had never
happened in a Star Wars movie before
it's a bit too on the nose and as much
as I'm saying the Last Jedi has divided
the fan base a divided fan base and or
an angry fan base is nothing new to Star
Wars just worth addressing because these
new Star Wars movies were supposed to
bring it all back that's not new to Star
Wars it feels new because social media
is just what it is it's enormous that's
how we get most of our interaction but
it's not new if you really feel like
that is new that means you were on the
what I'll call right side of Star Wars
history when the prickles came out it
means you probably hated the prequels
and you said midichlorians were an
Abomination and Jar Jar Binks was
horrendous but when the prequels came
out if you were out there going you know
midichlorians were a great idea and Jar
Jar Binks was hilarious then you knew
right then and there that angry fan
backlash all the Venom and ire that we
see right now it was around back then I
mean look at Jake Lloyd he burned all of
his Star Wars toys all the Star Wars
paraphernalia and he said his school
life was a living hell because of Star
Wars and it was because of Star Wars
fans to him myself included I've said
things that weren't so nice about his
performance I feel bad about it because
it's easy to forget they're human beings
or just look at the maker of Star Wars
himself George Lucas in an interview he
said why would I make any more when
everybody yells at you all the time and
says what a terrible person you are the
guy didn't want to make any more because
fans were mean people like me we were so
mean to him he quit
so yeah so it's always been around and
some movies should be divisive that's
actually a lot of fun mother is one of
my favorite movies that came out the
year it came out because people either
loved it or hate it and I just enjoyed
the conversations about it but when
you're holding one of the greatest most
beloved cinematic franchises in the palm
of your hand maybe don't use it to do
that little social experiment maybe try
to unite people under the flag of loving
it but it took rests yeah [ __ ] your
wife's friend is a risk it doesn't make
it good really if you look at the
marketing the setup the Cinematic
Universe they're building they are
making a Star Wars Cinematic Universe
they're essentially treating Star Wars
like Marvel but Star Wars does not like
the MCU Star Wars was never like the MCU
not all things are created equal that is
a phrase for a reason I was actually
talking with someone about the
chronology it used to be we got a Star
Wars Trilogy comprised of three movies
that were separated by three years each
and we got that treatment twice with 16
years separating the end of one Trilogy
in the beginning of another now in the
course of two and a half years we have
gotten Four Star Wars movies that's just
bad bafflingly fast for Star Wars but
Star Wars never thrived as a franchise
was just pumping out content for the big
screen it thrived by being the slow
crawl you had three years in between
movies it built the anticipation among
fans but after that first year you
didn't really think about it then the
next year you saw the marketing material
start to come the chatter was coming
through then you started getting
trailers just my memory of the prequels
coming out like that even though I have
my problems with the prequels the memory
of it the camaraderie among my friends
and I us talking about what's happening
next that's a lot of fun and it spans so
many years Star Wars has always thrived
by being a focused Saga a saga that the
filmmaker knew with the beginning Point
Middle Point and end point was going to
be Star Wars now just feels kind of like
a cluster [ __ ] we have these different
filmmakers one doesn't know what the
next one's doing I mean do you really
mean to tell me Ryan Johnson did what JJ
Abrams would have done had Abrams
directed The Last Jedi no he didn't
they're just on different pages it makes
the whole experience seem unfocused like
you have a drunk behind the wheel and
never drink and drive another complaint
I see is people say Star Wars is too
political which I take to be social
issues and the new movies do have some
heavy-handed social issues but they're
not woven into the plot I mean you can
argue and George Lucas I believe has
actually said that Palpatine is George
Bush so you can argue the prequels and
the rise to power is what Lucas felt the
Bush Administration might do point is
it's woven among the entire plot it's
not these one-liners characters say it's
not L-3 from solo a Star Wars story
sounding like she's reading hot take
tweets on social issues it's not like
that honestly I always felt Star Wars
was pretty agnostic when it came to
social issues and social justice I
always kind of felt it was theirs like
all right here's the galaxy far far away
here's the fun Space Opera with space
Wizards have fun I mean it always had
familiarity with our world sure Lucas
even said you have to make it familiar
enough for the fans to latch on to it
but still make it otherworldly like you
can't look like this world and sometimes
these new movies they feel like our
world it doesn't feel like a galaxy far
far away so it feels different whether
it be a line or a scene at Kanto bite
it's like yeah I read about that on
Twitter and that's why it's in here in
my observation I feel like the talk of
twin Twitter literally dictates what is
made for the big screen and Star Wars is
no longer separate from that the problem
with Disney Star Wars and how they
convey these social messages is how much
do they just stand out from the rest of
the plot and dialogue if it's a line
they speak there's always this pause and
just comes across as awkward if it's a
plot Point that's supposed to be a
metaphor or a mirror on our world it's a
useless one it never actually melds
merges and flows how I think they want
it to I mean I think we all agree that
social issues are worth talking about
and social change needs to happen I
think it's great that it is happening
but haven't we all been in that scenario
like where we're hanging out with
friends and we just want to hang out
with friends we're not on Twitter
because we don't want to see the good
fight right now we just want to relax we
want to talk about the good times we
want to have some enjoyment but then
there's that person that one of your
friends brought that keeps swinging the
conversation back into that direction
like dude there might be a new Fallout
game at E3 oh my gosh yeah speaking of
Fallout there's going to be a lot of
Fallout for that Donald Trump tweet I'm
telling you this is the year well yeah
probably
um how about this one dude in Doom I
just got this awesome gun dude it was
done huh yeah in Doom it was really cool
gun you kicked a lot of ass I see so
what do you play as a teacher in Doom
are you arming the teachers now what
what are you talking about let me ask
you this how many doors were there in
the building did it make a difference I
we just kind of want to talk and play
video games right now this comes across
as awkward I mean we've been there right
it's just it's all in context you got to
feel out the room I'm not even saying
Star Wars shouldn't be the platform
maybe it should it's not the 80s anymore
I mean what these movies have to do is
not make it so heavy-handed you have to
essentially trick the audience if you're
gonna have something that's going to be
a metaphor for real world [ __ ] you have
to have it woven into the plot in such a
slick way where when they're watching
the news later the person who watched
her movie's like oh man that kind of
reminds me oh
oh wow that was a metaphor for that
I totally get it now that's the point of
doing that having it so heavy-handed in
the dialogue having it stick out like a
sore thumb because it is a Bad plot line
that goes nowhere in your movie I think
is not only the least effective way to
do it it puts people off to it it turns
people off to it to people who would
otherwise be receptive I mean I would
think putting social or political issues
in your movie you do to reach the people
who otherwise wouldn't be on the same
page as you I think Disney needs to
pause and ask themselves why do they do
it do they do it to speak to the people
who already have their mindset so they
can all just go yeah totally or do they
do it to speak to people who otherwise
would not have their mindset to try to
show them the other perspective so they
can go oh that's an interesting
perspective I didn't think about that
and that's a question for Disney really
but I think the second scenario of
reaching people who otherwise wouldn't
be on your mindset is a more worthy
cause at least it'll do something at
least it has an effect otherwise it's
just an echo chamber of people who
already agree and what good is that but
because Disney's execution on the matter
is not cloaked in any form of nuance I
have to assume it's them doing the first
thing them forming an echo chamber
speaking to the people who already agree
with them reminds me of those people on
Facebook who unfriend everybody who
doesn't agree with them politically then
they give political posts but you're not
you're not spreading a message just
talking to people who already agree with
you just maybe Star Wars is not the
Escape maybe it's not meant to be it's
it's 2018 now movies are different your
movie going experience will be different
I suppose if you want Star Wars with
less social justice commentary you have
the original trilogy go enjoy it I mean
really if you look at Star Wars in the
past the metaphors and The Parables they
had in there they were generally things
people could see as metaphors for our
world Palpatine to follow the Republic
the rise of the empire me and George
Lucas's metaphor for the Bush
Administration is the most on the nose
thing but it's different because it
transcends that you could take that back
to Julius Caesar really any fall of a
republican Rise of an Empire that's
happened a lot the cautionary tale of it
could happen again and that cautionary
tale is still applicable now and will
still be applicable in the future
essentially the theme is applicable to
us but also Timeless will always be
applicable I feel like what Disney is
doing in putting these social issues and
political issues in their movies is it
issues that are monetizable and
hashtagable now which locks Star Wars
into now years down the road film
schools will look back at that time when
Twitter had a big hand in what got made
and presented on the big screen and the
Star Wars movies were movies that took
part in that of that time essentially
makes Star Wars feel smaller and in the
end they'll be like but is the Republic
gonna fall and are we going to become an
Empire that's still a very applicable
message now all that being said the
question is does it matter that's the
question for you to ask yourself here's
my tag I mean in the end this is the
important thing to remember Star Wars is
just a movie and if a movie can
illustrate something that can better the
lives of real people I feel like that's
a worthy thing to do people are what
life is about not movies I know shocking
that a movie reviewer says that but it's
true so Disney I think your heart is in
the right place just your head's up your
ass it's about how you address it
because if you address it so
heavy-handed on the nose it's going to
turn people off to it people who would
otherwise get the message and appreciate
the message because it was woven into a
good plot didn't stand out like a
soreathon I think in the end if Disney
changes their tactics I think people who
just want The Escapist fun of star Wars
and people who want to see the issues
addressed in Star Wars can both get what
they want but it's all about execution
and I hope you don't see this as me
flipping my perspective on Star Wars I
was super jacked when the force awakens
came out I've been super jacked for the
last couple years but just life is life
and here is a big fundamental thing
about life you get new data you process
that new data and then your mindset kind
of changes I've had a couple years to
process these new Star Wars movies it's
just what I say I get the feeling if I'm
jumping to a conclusion and I might be
reviewers out there will review a movie
or view a movie a certain way and if the
perception on it changes they're not
allowed to say it they have to above all
other things stand by and defend their
initial outlook on the movie I just
Life's too short for that [ __ ] [ __ ] that
you get new data all the time you
process that new data come to a
different conclusion different Outlook
I'm gonna blow your mind right now any
and every movie reviewer out there that
you watch has changed their mind about a
multitude of movies but they can't say
it so they don't have some of that truth
but I essentially did this to start a
conversation so the current state of
Star Wars what do you see why what do
you think about it do you think it could
get better do you think he's just fine
right now whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]